did you watch the Oscars last night or
are you just waiting for the internet to
tell you the juicy gossip I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news updates there
was some big and unexpected winners last
night from journalistic expose movie
spotlight winning Best Picture despite
the revenant enoree to winning Best
Director to winds that normally go
together to Leo's triumphant and
long-awaited Best Actor win for his role
in the revenant Leo speech highlighted
climate change but didn't mention his
meme worthy wait for the win and of
course the camera was ready to catch
Kate Winslet's adorable reaction Mad Max
meanwhile walked away with six wins
including hair and makeup costume design
and sound editing which is the most
technical awards an Australian film has
ever won the revenant was the second
biggest winner of the night with three
wins including Best Cinematography and
of course Leo's big win Chris Rock's
second time at hosting the ceremony was
full of references to the hashtag Oscars
so white problem but also poked fun at
Will Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith
boycotting of the night and invited
stacey dash on stage to make a wig not
very well-received joke about Black
History Month I cannot wait to help my
people out happy Black History Month
thank you meanwhile Sam Smith speech for
the best original song award received a
bit of flack after he mentioned that he
might be the first openly gay Oscar
winner sorry Sam but you're not one
example is dustin lance black who won
for Best Original Screenplay for milk
who sent this tweet in reply and Mark
Ruffalo tried to steal a big Oscar I'd
love to get your opinions on the 2016
Oscars in the comments but if you'd
rather just leave your favorite Leonardo
DiCaprio meme that's cool too you can
also find me on Twitter how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot